Louis rubialis why have you agreed to do
this interview with me
hello Pierce I think it's an opportunity
it's an opportunity you are a leader of
opinion A lot of people million people
follow you
and I think that a lot of people
millions of people
have an opinion about me about what
happened
um
for me like I tell you it's an
opportunity to to tell what really
happening um to give the truth to the
rest of the people now those because of
the legal action that you're now facing
you want to do the rest of the interview
in Spanish and we have a translator who
will translate as we go and we'll
explain that to the viewers so they
understand why you're not going to
switch into Spanish yes and I want to
say thank you because I know that
is better for you if we do everything
English in English but I feel
comfortable if I speak in my language
course I don't want to have any mistake
in the translation or something like
this and I will be comfortable doing and
answering my I would rather the
everything that you want to say is how
you want to say so we'll do it in
Spanish and that's not a problem
um
Lewis it's been three weeks today since
the Women's World Cup final
and that was when you planted this kiss
on one of the players
which has turned out to be the most
notorious kiss in history
and it's turned your life upside down
how have the three weeks been for you
for me I have been outside of this
tsunami
mediate
but at the same time with my family I
have suffered with my friends I have
suffered
and a lot of people have been telling
lies
he
and with all these lies the truth hasn't
surfaced so obviously with all those
lies the truth has not surfaced and I
would like to keep my opinion here on
this
um
materials
[Music]
do you accept that what you did
with that kiss was wrong
um
of course I have said it from the
beginning I made a mistake
and I apologized in a sincere manner
I was very happy I felt like another
player but being the president of the
association I have apologized
unreservedly that is not the actions of
the president of the association
why did you kiss Jenny Hermosa
it was a mutual act she came towards me
very happy she Lifted Me Up She lifted
me up in the air
when we hit the ground there was a quick
conversation there was a quick
conversation when we hit the ground we
were both emotional we congratulated
each other I gave her a quick pick I
asked her can I give you a quick Peck
which is normal in our country
Alegria
is
I think she gave me one or two slabs in
my side she was laughing and that was it
no intention of course no sexual
connotation of anything in just a moment
of Happiness just great joy in that
moment
but another
I want to show you a video which is
shows what was going on on that Podium
with some of the other girls too so
Lewis this shows what is going on on the
podium here
and you're picking up quite a few of
these girls you're hugging them you're
kissing most of them
as well but on the cheek
and I was struck by that that it's very
tactile I mean more than you would
expect perhaps from someone in your
position
[Music]
s
all the medal celebrations with guys and
girls all those celebrations are mutual
they're normal
um
a couple of minutes before they Lifted
Me Up amazing Harmony everyone is happy
fantastic
[Music]
I think Latin people and it's a cultural
question
tactile it's pretty normal in a Latin
World between guys and girls guys and
guys girls and girls and it's just
normal to that level of excitement and
happiness that we failed during that
final
foreign
men's team had won the World Cup
would you have interacted with those men
the same way would you have hugged and
kissed them
no doubt about it 100
there was a case with a manager on the
lips
and also when I was a player there were
many moments where we avoided relegation
or we got promotions
where we have given what we call pecks
on the lips many many times when they
were happy times
[Music]
the problem for many people
is that when you came to Jenny hello sir
you kissed her you've held her head with
your hands and you pulled it towards you
and you kissed a full on the lips
and many people think that was
completely inappropriate behavior
a lot of people have seen this still
image a lot of people have seen still
images of that or indeed the case which
lasted two tenths of a second yes it was
a moment of fusion in fact just before
that Danny lifted me off the ground she
didn't ask me it was just a moment of
happiness
sobre
una parte De La Storia
people who see that have no context to
this
it was an anecdote but I do recognize
that
as president I shouldn't have done it
appears as important
Pierce what you need to also understand
is that she all during this time on the
podium she's holding me she's laughing
as she moves away she continues to laugh
and she's saying things exactly those
that I am repeating here in front of you
today your position is
that she lifted you up and that you
asked her if you could kiss her and she
said yes
so people have read my lips unheard and
you can see what he said clearly
the ACT she lifted me beforehand that's
clear that's on the video everyone can
see that
and I'm going to maintain the same line
that I have given for the past three
weeks Jenny hermoso in a live Instagram
broadcast from the dressing room said
yeah it happened the kiss but I didn't
like it
you're her boss you're the boss of the
Spanish Football Federation well
technically you are
well
the content is so friendly it is jokey
she's laughing you have to take the
context in which that was done
even on the day she invited me into the
dressing room to announce that the
government will give a holiday in Ibiza
for all the players we are giving a few
days
I went into the dressing room to give
the message afterwards you have to
understand that when you say I am her
boss there is no relation I'm the
president I don't pick the team
I am the President of the Football
Association the Spanish Football
Association
it's true you are you're the but you're
the figurehead of Spanish football
and in that interview so and in that
Instagram live we also see that you say
that you want to marry Jenny when you go
to Ibiza which may be a joke uh but also
some people may see that and see that
maybe your motives were more than just
friendly no that actually you did have
some sexual motivation otherwise why
would you want to marry her
I'm glad we are here talking in front of
millions of viewers
it was a joke I mean there is absolutely
nothing
is
she has a partner I didn't go to Ibiza
it is impossible that there is anything
there there's absolutely nothing it was
a joke
but Lewis you can understand perhaps
that people have watched you single out
Jenny I'm also on the podium for the
only kiss on my lips and then in the
dressing room you make a joke as you say
about wanting to marry her you can see
why some people
think hang on a second this is really
inappropriate behavior by the president
of the Spanish Football Federation
I understand that somebody could
possibly misunderstand I also understand
that there are people who understood
very well but Twisted the information
my videos
there are lots more videos where you can
see me celebrating with all the other
girls in a normal excited fashion as you
would do on one of your best days in
your life
is
Amigos
you can imagine if you win the lottery
or hopefully soon one day the war in the
Ukraine finishes I mean celebrations
Will Go On Up and Down The Globe people
don't ask permission it's just a happy
happy time and people celebrate but it's
important in the celebration not only me
doing things no
the most of times they doing thing to me
hitting me
calling me Ruby that is like my friends
call me and this kind of things you know
was very familiar atmosphere and very
famous familiar celebration but there
will be people who hear you say that and
say come on you're not gonna seriously
be playing the victim here
I respect I respect everybody all
Educators opinions what I don't respect
is opinions of people who are trying to
twist the truth
my mom is in this my dad my kids have
been insulted
these are stand out to be a snowball
created by spurious arguments on people
my intentions were Noble enthusiastic a
hundred percent non-sexual 100 I repeat
a hundred percent is
foreign
uh logo
so Liz I want to show you another video
this is on the team bus
after the victory
and you see Jenny there she's laughing
and joking she's actually showing her
teammates pictures of Ikea Casillas with
his girlfriend who was at TV reporter
next to a picture of you kissing her on
the podium people were comparing the two
and she's drinking beer and she's
laughing with the other teammates
and then a little later you see the the
teammates and Jenny or or mainly the
teammates singing there Baza Baza Baza
Baza which is kiss kiss kiss and they
all seem to be laughing and finding this
funny you're actually at the back of
that of that coach and you arrive from
the back
and they start to charm Prezi Prezi
which is you the president
when you watch that what what are you
seeing here
is
so what I see is a video whereby the
whole team the staff after having won
the World Cup are having fun I hear the
chanting I hear the chanting pressy Ruby
these are words that my friends use
I was half behind I came up to
acknowledge I was a little bit ashamed
to be honest and I said I'm going to go
back to the back of the bus and sit down
um
why were you feeling ashamed
so they were asking me for a kiss that's
why I was a little bit embarrassed
what I would like to do is read you a
message of my phone from somebody who
was on the bus
this explains what happened
the stuff
23rd of August three days
I have got lots of messages for all
sorts of people players friends family
Etc this particular one was three days
after the match officios
good morning I would like to give you
thanks Eternal thanks for everything
that you have done for us president
yes you have given everything for us in
order to achieve the goal of the World
Cup final
I am very thankful to be able to live
one of the best moments of my life with
my family over there
I want to give you all my love in these
difficult times
what we have achieved is amazing huge
and that's thanks to you
don't Cloud anyone's judgment by these
people who want to ruin you
I know you're amazing you're strong and
I know you will continue to fight Ruby a
big embrace
so on the 25th 26th this person plus 10
more wrote a note to say that my Act was
misogynistic
antes
so what I asked myself is between the
message that I've just read
and Pierce is one I have a lot of them
but that was one of the 11 female
coaches is one of the staff technical
stuff a woman or a man no I'm not going
to to he said it was one of the eleven
from a woman and a half for me I
understand but on the particular one
you're talking about if I saw if I saw
you uh I I I'm not going to I'm going to
a criminal court now no I understand but
my point is all right all the 11 members
I can say to you but I can't answer you
don't understand what you said it's one
of the eleven it was the 11 female
coaching staff who resigned that day no
no no no no I think you are speaking
about the the footballers that didn't
want to come no no I'm talking about the
female members of the coaching staff
he's saying men and women that resigned
but you're not your point your point
Lewis is we don't know who that is and
obviously I can't verify that but if
what you're saying is true what you're
saying is there were people sending you
supportive messages who then resigned
and said what you had one was outrageous
I don't want to judge but when you have
such a huge current a torrent against I
don't want to be a judge when you have
got a current against one person a
tyrant a current
it's very very difficult it's given me
huge problems in life
I can't understand that people have
missed out on jobs and everything but I
am an honest guy and this is just not
right
foreign
there are pitches and video footage of
Prince William the Prince of Wales at
the Euros final of the women zeros final
a couple of years ago and he is greeting
the England lionesses who won but he's
far more reserved he shakes their hands
if they ask him for a hug he leans in
and hugs he doesn't kiss anybody do you
wish with hindsight
and hindsight's a great thing but you
wish with hindsight you would behave
more like Prince William did on that
occasion
um
so I have a lot of respect for the royal
family I'm not going to enter into
debates about the Royal Family
I have met King Charles years ago I know
him I have apologized for this
I have apologized on several locations
so if you are asking me in hindsight
would I do it differently of course the
intelligent answer is yes of course
foreign
I have said on many occasions I made a
mistake but do you think it's normal
that when I am on the street people stop
they wish me all the best they put their
kids up towards me to take some selfies
Que
ens
do you think that's normal behavior if I
was a sexual predator or if I commit as
an act of sexual violence or
error
I accept I have made a mistake but this
this is something else
I've talked to a lot of people in my
last three weeks about you about what
happened
an opinion is very split some people
think what you did was appalling they
think you're a sexist pig you should be
fired immediately other people think
there's been an overreaction and that
the attacks on you have got out of hand
other people aren't sure what to think
they know we live in different times
they know that the kind of thing that
you did now offends a lot of women
perhaps 30 years ago it wouldn't have
caused such offense but today it does
different times different moral code
which of those do you think best
reflects the reality
foreign
there's a different way to think many
many millions have seen this story
around the world
what they have seen however is limited
information
in Spain we have seen nearly all the
information however what is published is
very different to the sentiment that I
am seeing on the street information
because I don't hide I don't bow my head
I am on the street I'm not hiding and
the information that is published in
Spain very very different to the public
opinion on the street the kiss cause a
lot of controversy but certainly
something else you did that day
you were sitting just a few seats away
from Queen Leticia and Spain and her 16
year old daughter infanta Sephia the
princess
and you very provocatively grabbed your
crotch
in a way that frankly I watched that and
thought that just with members of the
royal family sitting there and a young
16 year old girl again was completely
inappropriate
for this I am truly ashamed more from an
internal perspective
there are no excuses
in Spain with guys as well as women
there's an expression which would
probably translate to something like
oh my genitals or something to that
respect
is foreign
when the final whistle went Jorge bilda
looked at me and said this is for you
gesturing quite strongly Victoria
I just your back and said no no this is
for you this is for you for all the
suffering we have had um
momento
cuando element
s
and so I made a gesture it was
unfortunate but I didn't it wasn't in a
negative connotation it was to say Bravo
well done
do you apologize to the queen have you
personally apologized to her no of
course I I couldn't have the opportunity
to to speak with
with the queen would you like to
apologize to her now no no yes I did I
did I mean directly to her yes of course
again and all the times and of course
they all the royal family they know me I
I know or King and is a top man in a
spectacular man
um I know him near 15 years ago or 14.
um
I hope they will know
um anything is going again anyone but I
apologize because it's not the behavior
I had to to have
your initial reaction on the night when
people started to criticize what you'd
done with the kiss in particular was we
do not pay any attention to idiots and
stupid people it was a pact between two
friends celebrating something the
criticism is really all just nonsense
from and dumbasses these are
just losers who do not know how to see
the positive side do you regret
expressing yourself like that
so I'd like to make a reflection here
regarding my arrows in the beginning I
spoke to several members of the press
who said no this is nothing it's just a
smaller nectar
in the beginning I spoke to several
members of the press who said no this is
nothing just a small anecdote no big
deal
we think the exact same as you but
at some stage at some moment this has
changed and is now being viewed in an
entirely different context
the next day August 21st the rfef
released a statement to the Spanish news
agency efe quoting Jenny hermoso as
saying it was a mutual totally
spontaneous gesture because of the huge
Joy of winning a World Cup the Prezi
rubiales and I have a great relationship
it was a natural gesture of affection
and gratitude
did you know about that statement before
it was made public
I think I have heard apart from this I
have also heard in many instances in
social media and interviews with Jenny
said this is spontaneous nothing but an
anecdote but but really I don't think I
want to enter into this anymore just to
focus on myself
um
she said she never said those things
I have heard it on the radio
so she's lying
no I'm not going to answer that but
there you have the radio you can listen
to the radio yourselves
um form your own opinions
this isn't good for anybody but I'm not
going to call anybody anything
on your way back from Australia you stop
at Doha and you issue a video apology
saying it was two friends celebrating
you ask viewers to ignore it as an
insignificant show of affection and you
round it again on the losers fools
nonsense and idiots looking to make more
of it people have said that by doubling
down in the way that you did no
and calling it a Witch Hunt that you
were sounding like Donald Trump no no
I don't know where this information is
coming from basically when the plane
stopped for a temporary stop I didn't
talk about idiots losers fools I don't
know what this information is coming
from
I have come here to tell you the truth
nothing about losers fools idiots
nothing about that
we are talking about the video in Doha
the Spanish prime minister Pedro Sanchez
after seeing the video
he said I think that what we saw was an
unacceptable gesture the original kiss I
also believe the apologies that Mr
rubiales has given are not enough I even
believe they are not adequate and that
therefore he has to continue taking
steps the acting Deputy Prime Minister
Yolanda Diaz later went further
said you should stand out she said
you've represented the worst of society
and called your behavior sexual
aggression so give me your reaction
first to the prime minister's comments
that he didn't feel you went far enough
with the apology
I'm not going to comment on the
presidents on the vice president but
what is clear is that I put myself at a
disposal of FIFA's body a psychologist
with anything they want to find out
logo
the apartment
also aboard Integrity board with
anything they want to find out and
what's true is I'll put myself at a
disposal of any other board with any
information they want to find out
because nobody wants the truth more than
I do
finale there was as you know a furious
response that built up over the days
after the final
from The Wider football world including
the England lionesses who'd been
defeated by the Spanish team in the
final
every single member of the lionesses
tweeted the following
unacceptable actions allowed to happen
by sexist and patriarchal organization
abuse is abuse and we have all seen the
truth the behavior of those who think
they are invincible must not be
tolerated and people shouldn't be
convincing to take action against any
form of harassment we all stand with you
Jenny hermoso and all players of the
Spanish team what was your response to
that tweet that they all tweeted
so once again I'm not going to comment
on third parties but what I want to say
is that this is not a debate about men
or women Progressive or conservative
this is a debate about the truth
under no circumstance was there any
aggression and under no circumstance was
there any sexual content that much is
evident by the actions of everything
that you can say
yes
[Music]
so when when the England lionesses every
one of them every woman in that team
tweet that it was abuse and we've all
seen the truth
are you saying they're wrong
I don't want to comment on Fair parties
I don't want any more Wars here
I know the truth I don't want to comment
on that okay I know the truth
in life mistakes are made but I'm very
calm with my innocence
what's important to me are the people
close to me and I am very calm about
this
is
I want to say that again I've made a
mistake I apologize but let's be clear
under no circumstances is this sexual
aggression
no abuse
celebration
of course not of course not it's an
effusive happy moment it's the same line
that I have given from day one
Woody Allen the Hollywood director who's
had his own problems with allegations of
sexual misconduct and abuse which he's
always denied
he came out and defended you
he said the kiss on the soccer player
was wrong
but it didn't burn down a school he has
the duty to apologize and go ahead they
didn't hide he didn't kiss her in a dark
alley he wasn't raping her it was just a
kiss and she was a friend what's wrong
with that
um
are two of the only directors that would
drag me to the cinema with my daughters
not wanting to talk about third parties
I won't comment on this
opinions
just to say that the people who have all
the information but not part of it it's
clear there was a mistake but it's also
clear there's nothing more there's no
sexual harassment violence or anything
like that
foreign Lewis you've said the at your
press conference on the 25th of August
you said that you were the victim of
false feminists what did you mean by
that
so first of all it wasn't in a press
release it was in the extraordinary
annual general meeting what I wanted to
do was to focus on my defense this issue
as far as I am concerned is part of a
bigger concept and that's it that's
where that came from
defensive
you have three daughters they're all
quite Young
how difficult has this been for them the
last three weeks
[Music]
so I am very lucky I've got three
beautiful mature yes but sensitive
soldiers
I think they are suffering more for me
for my parents than for themselves
they have friends sometimes they call me
to give me strength
foreign
[Music]
I don't delve into anyone's private life
and I don't appreciate that the Press
are telling into my daughter's lives
I've never talked about anybody's
private life
foreign
have you had some very emotional
times during this period
um
I've had support from my mother my
father cousins nephews nieces
the media
then through the
the it comforts me a lot to the people
the ones I love are close to me and also
people I don't know who come and provide
me with a certain amount of closeness
of course it's very comforting of course
I would have prefer not to go through
all of these for sure
your mother went on Hunger Strike she
went to a Catholic church and went on
hunger strike and ended up after two
days being taken to hospital
from the effects of the hunger strike
what was your reaction when she told you
what she was doing
it
I was yesterday with my mothering my
city my town
I bought her the ice cream that she
loves
spent a little bit of time with her but
it's true that I was very scared for her
at a certain point her uncle's
completely swelled up she suffers from
hypertension
listen we spent a nice moment
I have no doubt my mother would do
something similar unconditional love of
a mother is a powerful thing but did you
fear when she was taken to hospital that
you might lose your mother
that she would give her life for you
then Pierce I have no dude your mother
is a great woman
um well my my mother I
I was thinking see see
she is 72 years old and she has some
problems then when she called me to say
that
it's in 1920 and here in the church and
I say okay I'm going for you no no the
child is closed five minutes ago and I
I'm here I'm going to uh let's stay here
and say
who else
I really
remember that I
I thought one problem more
but see
she think that's probably
she is helping me and
she did no no no more words to just play
we've gone to a situation now where FIFA
suspended you for 90 days
a letter signed by 81 Spain players
including the entire world cup winning
Squad
was released saying they wouldn't play
until you were gone
they described your actions as violating
the Dignity of women
the letter also included the statement
from Jenny hermoso saying she had not
consented to the kiss or lifted you in
the air
and quoted her as saying I feel obliged
to report that Mr Louis Rubio's words it
explaining the unfortunate incident on
categorically false and part of the
manipulative culture that he himself has
generated I want to make it clear that
at no time did the conversation to which
Mr Louis Rubios refers to in his address
take place and above all was his kiss
ever consensual I want to reiterate as I
did before I did not like this incident
when you read those words what did you
feel
so in regards to the non-consensual the
picking up we have already talked about
that
the FIFA
FIFA
in regards to FIFA temporary the process
was very very quick unprofessional
foreign
Executives in Latin America at five or
six in the morning
so they made a quick decision to suspend
me without giving me the chance to build
the defense objectively I think that was
completely wrong
sing
fundamentos
on
principio so whilst I believe we need to
respect innocence until proven
guiltyonador
in the same World Cup it was an act of
sexual violence that hasn't been dealt
with and is ongoing
suspended
yeah it's in my case this has been done
and dusted and a provisional 90-day
sanction made within hours
you think that's hypocrisy double stand
I am a lawyer I don't understand the
fact that I haven't been able to defend
myself before or after I am a lawyer I
don't understand
it's on
the your Federation
following this statement from the
Spanish players and the statement from
Jenny hermoso threatened Hermosa with
legal action and said that you're
telling the truth thereby implying that
she was lying with hindsight again was
that a mistake for the Federation to put
that out they then deleted it but was it
a mistake to Target Jenny hermoso in
that way and call her a liar I can't
remember what the communication says
there's a lot of stuff now I can't
exactly remember the communication it
was it was deleted I think that what I
would say to you is
a lot of women have written or tweeted
or said
that they've been in similar situations
where somebody higher up than them
at work or wherever it may be a play a
person in a position of more power like
you in the Spanish football world
may do something inappropriate and in
the moment you go along with it because
you're celebrating winning the World Cup
and you don't give it as much thought as
you might and then the next day when you
see the media coverage and you see the
pictures and the videos you feel
humiliated I've seen women write this
who've been through something similar
albeit different
do you accept that perhaps Jenny hermoso
in the moment
Maybe
was celebrating and just thought okay
it's okay but that she the more she
thought about it the more she felt
violated
I have said My Story in all of these it
is the truth I'm not going to change it
I think one of the reasons that you're
in the problem that you're in
is that
your Federation publicly called Jenny a
liar and said you were telling the truth
well in fact it's a complicated
situation with two different
Recollections of what happened and it
may be she's being as honest as you are
in her head about what she felt actually
happened there and it may be you feel
the same way and so there's a
disagreement there but for your
Federation to publicly trash her I felt
that was unacceptable Behavior by the
Federation and if you're Jenny hermoso
you've been humiliated you've been
called a liar to the world and that may
be why she's now taken the further
action that she's taken
so with a judicial review I'm not going
to comment on that okay I think what's
important is that I focused on what
happened I can't talk about what other
players said so the manager said
different federations you know it's down
to the judge and what I need to focus on
now is my honor and respect
you know I was thinking if Prince
William who's president of the Football
Association here
if he had done to one of the England
lionesses had they won the game and if
he'd been there he should have been
there but he wasn't there if he had
pulled one of their faces towards him
and kissed him on the lips there would
have been real outrage around the world
but also this country people would have
thought that was completely outrageous
behavior
[Music]
I have read your Twitter I know you are
an honorable man of that I'm sure but
I'm sure you have made many mistakes in
your time but that doesn't classify you
as somebody that commits sexual violence
the issue in question here is that and I
have set this 10 15 times I have made a
mistake I have made a mistake it is how
you categorized that mistake that is
what we are talking about here
foreign
yeah I I completely agree the problem
you have is that on September the 8th
Jenny Hermosa filed a formal legal
complaint against you which will now
proceed through the criminal courts
alleging assault and there was a further
allegation of coercion with hermoso
telling the prosecutor that her
relatives had suffered pressure from you
and your professional Entourage to say
that she Justified and approved what
happened
what was your feeling when you heard
that she was making him as a criminal
prosecution
I have never pressurized anybody into
anything you categorically deny that a
hundred percent a hundred percent and
nobody in your entourage your team has
put any pressure on Jenny Hermosa
I have never pressurized anybody I had
never sent anybody to pressure anyone
there was an allegation that Jorge
Wilder who was the coach of the women's
team who initially supported you he
applauded you when you gave your
statement in public and then said your
behavior was unacceptable and was a
macho attitude there was an allegation
that he had tried to persuade Jenny
hermoso to be supportive towards you is
that true who said this that he had
tried to persuade General Mercer to be
supportive towards you have you heard
that
is
[Music]
perhaping many many people with
apparition
is
that question has changed again I'm not
going to talk about third parties I
would be very very happy for all the
hours of video all the hours every
single one of the videos to come out in
the public domain I will have no
problems
there's been a strong reaction from the
Spanish men's players both current and
past issued a statement of solidarity
the Spanish Spanish men's team Striker
Boyer Iglesias quit International
Football in protest
Sergio Ramos one of the greats of
Spanish football said you behaved in an
unacceptable manner you made a mistake
instead of talking about rubials we have
to take the opportunity to congratulate
the women's team the world champions
that's what we should be talking about I
hope the football has the
representatives it really deserves and
Hector bellerin used to play for my team
Arsenal put a statement on Instagram
saying it's truly shameful what is
happening representing our country with
that vulgarity misrepresenting the
victim's statements on top of that
Having the courage to blame her going on
to victimize her for having committed
abuse of facts to which no one can go
unpunished football is a social tool to
advance and progress machismo should
have no place within this system The
Narcissist never believes they've made a
mistake he's capable of lying
manipulating the truth and making the
victim guilty in order to maintain his
power over others very strong words from
Hector bellerin
Pierce you can read me 2 000 or 2
million because everybody spoke about it
spoke before to see some videos and some
information others spoke after other
things what they say but when you're
called by an international
but here's my question when you're
called a lying narcissist who's going
after the victim that's going to hurt
isn't it I mean the international
pleasures
read communicate
so so similar if you
comparate that the word I say in the
general assembly that they had a mistake
very big mistake
I say I'm sorry essentially
um I think that they continue saying
that now they are going to focus in the
support side
then I upset and I don't want to comment
like everywhere everybody is speaking do
you accept the argument that your
behavior was Macho no and you don't no
my behavior
was inappropriate but no sexual content
no sense Macho doesn't have to do no
that show hasn't got to be sexual no
yeah but I'm going to ask you with a
question you did me some minutes ago
about the main thing did you do the same
you asked me before what I asked what I
answer you say you do this I did when I
was pleasure I kiss
and not to know to come and says
two tenths of seconds okay more close to
St Louis do you think I can see the
impact this is all had on you
and it's it's a very difficult thing to
be accused of what you've been accused
of
do you feel that now it's become a
criminal matter that this has got
completely out of hand do you think that
is
a massive overreach
on the
I am a lawyer I am a Spanish citizens
I have been through many processes
criminal as well
and nothing has ever stuck
if you were convicted that's a big if no
hello I don't know but if you work in
Victor well I have to ask the question
okay okay if you were convicted you
would face potentially a prison sentence
have you thought about that about the
worst case scenario that you might go to
prison for a kiss
again I have full faith that the truth
will come out and everything will be
fine
but you do not believe in your heart
that you're a criminal
yeah
foreign
take a look at my face I am a good guy
look at my face look at me in the eyes
the situation of Max happiness rid my
lips Max happiness when a war ends when
you win a World Cup and events like that
it's an amazing feeling it can be
nothing more than complete Joy
do you regret that all the attention
since the Spanish women won the World
Cup has been about you and your behavior
and not the women who won this amazing
tournament
it gives me an incredible amount of
sadness with the job that we've done
we've invested we build the budget from
3 million up to 27 million
professionalism
professionality that we've given to this
team we've got more teams below the
national side
it just makes me very very sad
it should have been the best day of your
career
and it turned out to be the worst
I am very happy I was very happy for us
to be champions
I made a mistake but it's not just about
my mistake it's about people
manipulating there's nothing casual
about this situation I have made one
error and we have categorized it
yo
what it's about for me now is to defend
my dignity
and that's something I will do yeah
when you played your nickname was
pundino which is Spanish for Pride
because of your tenacity and
hard-working style of play are you proud
of yourself as you sit here today
is
when you look back at one's life a man's
life one mistake can't Cloud everything
that a man does I said I'm sorry I said
it with sincerity
I hope I have some good health and I
have some years left to watch my
daughters turn into fabulous women
Thunder
you know we make honest mistakes I
haven't made them before
they have always been honest mistakes on
at no stage to hurt anybody
but another
I'm not talking about this mistake now
I'm talking about before but nothing
against my values
um
repeatedly that you're sorry for what
you did
but you haven't apologized directly to
Jenny Hermosa
now is your opportunity would you like
to apologize personally to her for the
way she was left feeling about this
so what happened is bad for everyone
we have Jenny Lifting me we have the
fleeting keys to tenths of a second
Alegria
he
what was created from that is crazy
so what's left is for me to defend my
dignity
I understand that but I also understand
that she feels very differently about
what happened
and it seems strange to me that you
would keep saying sorry for what you did
but you won't say sorry to the woman
that you did it to no so it's not about
that piece it's about humility
the principia
what we had in the beginning was two
versions that were exactly the same and
therefore an anecdote and now all I can
do is to understand that I have had from
the very first day
I'm going to try one last time
because you keep saying you're sorry and
you made a mistake and you shouldn't
have done it
but you won't say sorry to Jenny
personally and I'm curious why you're
reluctant to do that putting aside any
of the of the possible prosecution and
so on I'm just curious why you would say
yes I made a mistake yes I shouldn't
have done it I wouldn't do it again if I
had my time but you won't go that one
step further and just say Jenny I'm
sorry
so what we had is a spontaneous act a
mutual active
which was driven by the emotion of the
moment the happiness so I maintained
that that is the truth of what happened
so again just to be clear no sexual
content and everything that happened was
driven by the emotion
the effervescence of the day and the
happiness
if it was all
as you say
why was it such a big mistake
because a president Can't Behave that
way towards the executives of the game
on the podium
okay
cerma diplomatic yes a president can
give a hug but needs to act in a more
diplomatic and colder way
I agree with you
so if you accept that as president what
you did was wrong and it was a mistake
and it was inappropriate
there's only one woman you did that to
you didn't kiss any of the others on my
lips only Jenny Hermosa and whatever the
circumstances that led to that moment
which will happen very fast
and putting aside anything else
if you accept all that surely The
Honorable thing to do if you're an
honorable man is to accept that for
whatever reason she feels
having thought about what happened and
seen what happened
that she was violated in some way and
that it was made her feel bad wouldn't
The Honorable thing as a gentleman be to
say
I'm sorry
um
I have three daughters
uh
I have seen the reaction before during
and after
the antes Durante de pues do you know we
have a lot of the
Audra persona
it's implemented again I'm going to say
that this was all down to a very happy
moment a celebration a euphoric moment
there was no harm no sexual content no
aggression nothing like that
the significance of the keys to Jenny
would have been exactly the same as a
keys to one of my daughters
between friends and family that's very
very I understand but here's what I
would say if one of your daughters ends
up playing football for Spain
and she ends up winning the World Cup
and she goes up to get her medal and
there's a male president
who is much much older
and he grabs her and he kisses her on my
lips and she's the only one of the whole
team he does that to
and he admits afterwards he shouldn't
have done it and it was a mistake
I bet you as the father of your daughter
but the roles reversed a bit would say
he should just apologize to my daughter
again irrespective of who the father is
who the daughter is to consent in adults
in a moment that was Mutual
where she lifted me up
where I asked her a question that you
can clearly see
there was no intention
issues that actually this was just a
mere anecdote
but you understand she doesn't think it
was consensual I think I answered you
yeah I'm just saying you understand that
she doesn't agree I have my version if
other persons
Chinese version is not my
my
I don't know noise question let me ask
you Lewis when you when you were married
I know you're divorced now but with your
mother of your daughters I'm not going
to speak a while no no I'm gonna ask you
to I'm just right I'm not asking you to
I'm just going to ask you so much I'll
ask you one for the general question
sometimes in a marriage if the man
doesn't think he's in the wrong
but his wife does think he did something
wrong sometimes a man just says sorry
anyway
you don't feel that is
[Music]
I would say that this is not about
comparing this to a marriage or between
two partners or ideologies
this is merely a world happy event
to compare it there is no comparison
you've come under ferocious pressure for
three weeks now on you on your family
it's been very difficult for your
daughters or young girls I can only
imagine as a father myself I have a
daughter around the age of one of your
girls incredibly difficult
there comes a point perhaps
when the pressure is just so relent
relentless
that you do think about what you should
do
with yourself and your future
many people think you should resign as
president
what are you going to do I love so much
and they they love me so so much I
a very happy I'm very proud of them very
very proud soft and they are very near
to me
about marriage in nation yes I'm going
to do
I'm good you're going to result yeah I'm
going to yes because I cannot continue
my work
for for two or three or three reasons
first of all
I have a suspension
and this suspension is just starting
and is going to continue I'm sure
because if you can't see
how was down
is going to continue
at the same time
I think that the Federation
I is not a question about if I can
support or know this mediatic tsunami
it's about to know how is going to
affect to the Royal Spanish for
Federation and I love my country and I
love football and I don't want damage
for them
another third
I think about it is we
we are running for the World Cup in 2013
we made an incredible
a job during the last fun and health
yes we started Fernando Gomez the
blessing of Portuguese Federation and me
more than five years ago with this
um I think that
Now is better for this bit
for me to go out and I spoke
no directly but to refer and they are
agree then I cannot be egoist and to
take the chair and not to move myself
because the situation changed so much
from the moment I say I'm not going to
resign and now saying so so much in
three weeks I don't know is incredible
how
how fast can we sung institution what
was the final moment for you was it
talking to your family your dad perhaps
yeah my my father my daughters I spoke
with with them
um is not they know is is not a question
about me and some friends very very
close to me
and they say to me Luis now
you have to focus in your identity and
to continue your life
because
if not probably you are going to that
much people you love on the sport you
love and the beat you build with some
people long time ago now it's very very
near the resolution last September in
one year
then when someone is not thinking only
about
himself because I had to support a lot
on this three weeks but this uh more a
question of not only me
and then an attitude an attitude of me
can affect
third party is very important and this
is the in this situation now the more
intelligent and the thing I have to do
how do you feel now you've made that
decision to resign it's a huge thing to
do you have the most powerful job in
Spanish football you've loved that job
it should have been the greatest day of
your life winning the World Cup it's
turned out to be the worst day of your
career now you've lost the job that you
love how do you live is life life is
live and we had to to be open-minded
with this and continue
um uh
not to look at everybody what you had
one thing will come
but and good things for for sure
I'm going to work and I I'm young and I
I only hope to have health
to to be healthy to to here with my
family to work strong
whatever I'm going to do I had some
projects with
some people that were in apart because I
focus 100 of my life in football and I
hope now to
to start again with then another news
um of course I love so much and I was
very happy very happy this five years
with a lot of problems with pen
elections with all you can say
but I was fully happy
uh
being
involving 100 of my life with a Spanish
football and European footballers
that one kiss Lewis has turned out to
have
pretty horrendous repercussions for you
do you wish you'd never
could be worse people
um
sometimes has to go
with other more serious things and
football Spanish football can be calm
with this I always
act with
a honest honestly
then I'm thinking that finally I'm
speaking English with you
well I understand you wanted to speak in
Spanish because you wanted no no no no
no quoted accurately I understand okay
because you are facing comfortable
potential criminal I understand no no I
feel comfortable because this is not a
thing of my the criminal action of the
prosecutor again I didn't have the the
resolution but the media said that was
the prosecutor okay when I read I will
know but about football is so big and
will continue with with the best player
and we thought then because they are
coming back new people and and the the
Spanish Federation will be what do you
say would you say Louis to women
watching this who may only know about
you from what they've seen that day and
from what they've read since or seen on
television since about you what do you
say to women who think that what you did
was a real affront to women's football
to women
uh and they look at you and say why did
you do that well a woman full of all uh
no chance to to to comment the the
results sport result no chance to
comment uh the investment we did this is
completely the most important of the
history in these five years
and I'm proud of all my team that did it
possible
hung about women in the street when I
see then we were speaking before to
start the the interview with one friend
of me is coming with me and a lot of
people a lot of women say to me I'm with
you
you had a mistake but it's not what
people
say
in some media then be strong we are with
you we are with you
this is I don't know
I don't want to say a percentage but
I'm
reconfort
Comfort
comforted sorry but some people support
you yeah
not some I think
a lot of a lot of
but not because they are supporting a
mistake no they censored a mistake of
course
but they support me because this mistake
is not what other people are talking
about it's a mistake that cost you your
job
I think that
when you have a lot of people looking at
you
you have to be excellent
I don't know if 100 of time but in a lot
of time and I I was in excellent and
now I had to take a decision and like I
said to you is
to say I don't move
and to complicate the future of some
people on the sports I love and the
institution I love and the thing is
more generous and
have you told your daughters that you
are going to resign
in the moment I finish this interview
but they know me and
when when we spoke yesterday night about
the damage is receiving the Federation
today I received a call of one of them
coming here to
to England and
I know that they they know they know me
very well your daughters yeah
so they expect you to do this no they
they expect a
to me to be happy
to be happy to continue and to take
responsible decisions and it's
responsible not to damage other people
for one particular item of you finally
Lewis do you have a message for the and
I want to add one thing I I spoke with
my close thing the day before of the
general assembly and I said then
I don't want to resign
let's wait the two or three procedure is
in one month the decisions
if I continue with those problems I will
make a combocatory of Elections and they
all know this this decision they they
knew that I was thinking about to go or
no but finally I decided to continue
but now I don't have better way because
I'm going to to make make suffer make
pain distribution
I was pressing and it's not the correct
way
finally do you have a message for the
Spanish women's team because they won
the World Cup it should have been the
greatest thing of their lives and maybe
it will be down the line but for the
three weeks afterwards I hope all
they've had to talk about and read about
is you and the kiss and the crotch
grabbing and everything do you have a
message for them I I hope in the future
you can you can see I hope you can watch
what the meeting we have all is
in videos I hope
um I have a lot of text
um some messages with
Pleasures coaches
for me this is all happen cause after of
this
news and problems all chains then for me
the more the the pure is what I have
here and the conversation we have face
to face and between our
what's up you know
well Lewis I wasn't expecting you to
resign in the interview but I'm grateful
to you for your honesty today and
telling us that news and I guess in the
end people will watch the whole
interview
and they'll make their own minds up
about what they think of you I know from
talking to lots of people that there are
lots of different opinions about what
happened it is a complicated issue but I
wish you well and I appreciate the
interview thank you thank you very much
opinions
but I continue in my idea that one thing
is to have a mistake another thing is to
call one thing what is not thank you for
the opportunity you know that now that
we are in the end I have made it so much
and I never thought that I'm going to be
sitting with Michael Morgan I don't like
the I think I didn't think I'd be
interviewing Louis ribialis right but
you've become in the last three weeks
one of the most famous people in the
world not for the reason you don't like
football you have to support football
and to see more football you will be
more happy happier than you are
good to see you thank you very much
thank you